well it's been a long tough road for the
uh delusional unhinged Trump fraud
lawyer Sydney Powell but it does seem as
though her story has peaked and now we
are we're really in the danuban as I
like to say this might be the last piece
of the story as Sydney Powell has now
reportedly been banned from all of
Donald Trump's properties
recall that she's been a beleaguered
attorney for a while now early on in the
2020 voter fraud lies she was very
involved she appeared at that
mind-blowing press conference where Rudy
giuliani's hair dye melted all over his
face and that's the one where she made
the wild claims about Hugo Chavez and
Tifa Cuba some guy named Eric Coomer and
many others at some point Sydney Powell
clearly was working with Donald Trump
but soon after that outrageous press
conference the Trump campaign put out a
statement saying Sydney Powell is
working on her own trying to create
distance because what she did was so
humiliating but then she showed up at
the Oval Office so it really wasn't
clear what was take taking place well
now she's been totally disgraced we've
covered some of the really embarrassing
interviews that she gave in the last few
months her cohort Rudy Giuliani has been
sanctioned by various bar associations
Trump has seemingly abandoned both
Giuliani and Sydney Powell but now to
add insult to injury Powell is
reportedly on Trump's so-called no-go
list at his properties The Daily Beast
reports that quote since he left office
in January certain advisors and longtime
Associates to Trump have kept an
informal shortlist of people who they
should look out for including at Trump's
private clubs or offices in Florida New
Jersey and New York the point of this
roster is to intercept and possibly
rebuff attempted Outreach visits or
phone calls from a handful of
conservative figures who could bring the
ex-president more undesired headaches uh
this is expanded on further in a a Daily
Beast article which says
um what does it say Sydney is very much
on the no go list her problems right now
do not need to be the former president's
problems Powell's legal exposure right
now is of course massive and ever since
she tried to work with Trump to
orchestrate a coup last year against Joe
Biden feelings of frustration and
bitterness have lingered between Trump
and Powell but what that means is in the
end Trump will turn on you
in this case without you even
diminishing your support for him we know
that if you go from 110 supportive of
trump to 99 supportive Trump often turns
on you anyway in this case Sydney Powell
seems to have made maintained her
loyalty through and through she still is
repeating all the same stuff but here it
seems to be because she's so wacky that
Donald Trump is kind of backing off a
little bit I would imagine that Sydney
Powell thought
she was going to get massive rewards and
access and fame and power for spreading
the election lies about Trump and doing
the press conferences and the like she
did get Fame in a sense for being
completely whacked out and disconnected
from reality but we know what Trump does
when people are no longer useful to him
they might be no longer useful to him
because they've turned on him people
like Michael Cohen they might be no
longer useful to him because they don't
have any more money and the election is
over like his supporters so he just
tries to fleece them out of their last
pennies he doesn't care and they might
not be useful to him because like Sydney
Powell they've just been ridiculed and
made fools of so much in the media that
they can't do anything for him anymore
anymore and think about Sydney Powell
who would hire her now for actual legal
work
I wouldn't hire her for you know a real
estate closing never mind something like
what she was trying to do for Donald
Trump or anything in between quite
frankly so not going well for Sydney
Powell banned from Trump properties not
going well for Rudy Giuliani and what
there are lessons here and one of the
big big lessons seems to be
Donald Trump will turn on you no matter
how close no matter how much he seems to
like you he will turn on you and even
now there are reports we don't we don't
know to what degree they are true there
are reports that the relationship
between Trump and Ivanka as well as
Jared Kushner have started to
deteriorate because Ivanka seems to
think some of the stuff Trump has done
over the last few months continuing to
push the voter fraud lies is just making
him look bad which of course it is with
much of the world but his own supporters
absolutely love him for it so that's the
latest Rudy if you invested in Rudy's
stock you would be down right now if you
invested in Sydney Powell stock you
would be down even more
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the only subscription streaming service
dedicated to documentaries if you're
like me you're always watching
documentaries you want to find the best
ones and curiosity stream is really a
must-have curiositystream has a better
selection of documentaries than Netflix
Hulu or Amazon I just finished watching
wasteland about a landfill on the
outskirts of Rio in Brazil where men and
women sift through garbage uh in order
to try to make some money it's
horrifying but extraordinarily well done
they always have the newest and most
critically acclaimed titles when you're
looking for good documentaries use the
streaming service that specializes in
documentaries that's why I use
curiositystream they have documentaries
on politics economics history technology
psychology
everything if you love documentaries
you've got to have curiosity stream you
will see what I mean when you start
using it when you go to
curiositystream.com Pacman you'll get 25
off a subscription which comes out to
just 15 bucks a year the link is right
underneath this video